We just looked to an example where measuring coverage
was useful in finding a bug in a piece of code.
What I want to show you now is another piece of code. This would be a really quick example.
The coverage is not particularly useful in spotting the bug.
And so, what I have here on the screening is a broken function.
The job is to determine whether a number is prime.
That is to say, it doesn't correctly do its job of determining whether the number is prime.
So, let's look at the logic in this function. So, this prime takes a number.
If the number is less than or equal to 1 or divisible by 2, then it's not prime.
Now, once the number passes that test, what we are going to do is loop over every number
between 3 and the square root of the number
and check if the original input number divides evenly by that number.
If it does, then of course, we don't have a prime number.
And if all of those tests failed to find a divisor, then we have a prime number.
And so, as can you see, there is a little bit of test code here that checks
how this function responds for the numbers 1 through 5 and 23, 24.
And so, what to do is let's just run this code.
This code has correctly computed that 1 is not prime, 2 is not prime, 3 is prime, 4 is not, but 5 is.
Similarly, 20, 21, and 22 are not prime numbers. They all have divisors
23 is prime, and 24 is not.
So, for this 10 examples, this prime function has successfully identified
whether the input is prime or not--so, let's run the code coverage tool.
We got the same output. Now, let's look at the results.
So, we can see out of the 20 statements in the file, all of them run,
and none of them failed to be covered.
Statement coverage gives us a perfect result for this particular code and yet another set is wrong.
Here of the same code and ID, so let's run out.
The output is what we expect, and what I would like you to do is do 2 things.
First of all, at least 1 test case, where you check a value for prime and
the code here returns the wrong result.
And then second, create a new function is prime 2 that fixes the error.
That is to say a correctly identifies for any natural number input.
That is to say any input 1 or larger whether it's prime.